this is the war in which our fighting
men clash with the enemies of democracy
on a dozen far fronts
and here is the war in which we all
fight the war of production
in spite of our vast industrial
experience this new kind of production
for war presents more and greater
problems than our nation has ever had to
solve
aluminum for 50 000 planes a year
tires for a million fighting vehicles
clothes for 10 million soldiers and
powder for their rifles and machine guns
powder for torpedoes
powder for bombs
for more and more and yet more bombs 100
octane gasoline and special liquids to
cool the engines of the best fighters in
the sky
these are big problems so big that to
solve them will take the best efforts of
all of us the whole 130 million of us
our leaders
our production experts
our designers
our workmen
our miners
our farmers
oh yes we're depending on our farmers
their part in this war is second to none
of course everyone knows that farmers
grow our food but important as food is
that's not all they're doing
their job is even bigger than that
consider what the farmers of just one
part of our country are doing the
farmers of the south
these southern farmers are playing a
vital part in keeping our p-40s in the
sky
filling our arsenals with ammunition
helping speed the transport of war
materials
and supplying thousands of tons of
much-needed scrap to our steel mills
yes indeed the farmer's job in this war
is a big one
this man is not a farmer but he knows
how important they are to the war effort
no i'm not a farmer
i'm a specialist in explosives
developing new methods of producing gun
cotton
now strangely enough i've never seen
cotton growing
yet we use about six pounds of cotton
liners in every 10 pounds of gunpowder
renders you know is the cotton that's
left on the seas after it has jammed
explosives and plastics will take the
cotton liners from this year's entire
cup of 14 million bales
i guess it takes a lot of work to grow
14 million bales of cotton
yes a lot of work
and to grow a crop of about 14 million
bales takes 24 million acres of land
the work of about 2 million southern
farmers
plenty of work hard work for men women
and children all through the hot summer
months
and hard work for the land too
work which could eventually wear it out
but our farmers have learned to put
vitally needed chemicals back into the
soil
now however the nitrogen in chemical
fertilizers is also needed for
explosives so cover crops of legumes are
helping do the job
and we can be sure that each year the
land will be as good as before maybe
even better
and that we can continue to produce
enough cotton to meet the war needs of
ourselves and our allies
so
we're growing better cut too more and
more of it is the long staple variety
which means that each fiber is longer
and that threads made from it will be
stronger and lighter
this construction equipment helping to
drive the strategic alaskan highway
through to completion at 50 below zero
and these air cobras spitting lead and
explosive shells at 400 miles an hour
both owe something of their performance
to the farmer
how come
well
let this man tell you how come
antifreeze and the special fluids used
in our liquid-cooled aircraft engines
have a glycerin base most of which was
derived from oils that we used to get
from the east indies
now like with rubber we've had to find a
substitute
only this was easier because we can use
cottonseed and peanut oil in place of
many of these other oils and so release
them for war products
maybe we can't exactly say that we're
going to lick hitler with peanuts but
they're going to help
now that peanuts are more than just
something we eat at baseball games we're
going to need more of them and we're
getting more of them our farmers are now
harvesting about two and a half million
more acres of peanuts than before the
war
throughout the south wherever the soil
is suitable
peanuts are stacked like this for drying
during early fall
from virginia to texas
everyone pitches in to get the crop
harvested women folks drive tractors
the kids do what they can
and when threshing starts those goobers
really begin to pile up
of course to get this crop planted and
harvested takes real planning and
cooperation whole communities get
together to share new machinery
machines which just have to be shared as
there aren't enough to go around
steel that used to go into farm
machinery is now being made into ships
and tanks
ships and tanks and guns that we're
using to put the squeeze on hitler and
hirohito just like we're putting the
squeeze on mr goober to get that
valuable oil
after the oil is out what's left is made
into meal which is used to help feed the
extra livestock we're raising these days
nothing wasted
and that oil here it is
and it's one of the best cooking oils
known
and there's still some peanuts left for
those who like to munch them at the
movies
and of course plenty left to supply
peanut butter to the army because the
army considers it a vital food
especially for men in foreign fields
so you see this and every other farmer
with his field of peanuts is really a
defense industry
another of the farmer's important jobs
is that of easing the transportation
problem of helping trains
like this
carry more and more of the materials of
war
but let's hear from an expert on this
subject
no
well no
i'm not really an expert on
transportation
but i do feel that we women folks can do
a lot to help
by just growing and canning enough for
our own families for an entire year
that means things don't have to be
shipped to us that makes it easier for
the army to get the materials they need
to fight with
and besides that saves the tin cans for
the city folks who just naturally can't
grow and can things for themselves
and you know
i always feel there's more downright
goodness to the things i put up myself
that's the southern farmer's job in the
war
food and scrap oils and gunpowder bombs
and clothing
all war necessities depending on the
fields of cotton and peanuts the gardens
and pastures the tractors and mules and
depending on the men and women
work which may not seem as exciting as
building 30 ton tanks or four motor
bombers yet even in that the building of
four motored bombers our farmers have a
part
these young men your sons and the sons
of your neighbors in maine and minnesota
and oklahoma are about to take off on a
bombing rate over hitler's europe
about to take off in planes that every
farmer in america has helped to build
from your fields come the explosives in
these bombs the ammunition for these
guns the insulation for miles of wires
the plastics and the instruments and
gadgets facing the pilot oils and
fabrics and paints the very fields of
america and the heart of our hills
forged by the skill of our workmen into
weapons of freedom and if we from day to
day do our jobs as well as those who
fight the cause of freedom for all men
is well served